اسود الاطلس يصنعون التاريخ دموع الدون
وسيدتي الجميله تودع الرياض بعد الجدل
اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
جعلوا الحلم حقيقه واسعد وطنا وقارا
المنتخب المغربي لكره القدم اسود الاطلس
كانوا الابرز الاسبوع الماضي عالميا
وفعلوا ما لم يسبقهم اليه احد عربيا
وافريقيا لوصولهم الى المربع الذهبي في
مونديال قطر 2022 بعد ان اقصى ومنتخبي
اسبانيا والبرتغال من ربع النهائي بساله
ياسين بونو في الدفاع عن علي اسود الاطلس
قفزه يوسف النصيري وصور الاحتفال مع
المدرب وليد الركراكي والامهات ستحفر في
ذاكره المغاربه طويلا املا بالوصول الى
اقصى مسافه ممكنه في الحلم وربما رفع كاس
العالم الاسبوع المقبل
فلوس ايه
يا رسول الله اله
الصد سيدنا محمد
الارجنتيني للوصول الى المربع الذهبي بعد
مباراه متوتره معه هولندا اقصى فيها راقي
سلطان تانجو الطواحين العنيده وكذلك نجح
مودريتش بقياده المنتخب بلاده كرواتيا الى
المربع الذهبي في مباراه مجنونه اقصى قسيس
سامبا من البطوله وابكت نيمار الذي ذاق مع
رفاقه مراره خساره البرازيل في الدوري
الربع النهائي من مونديال قطر 2022
لكن دموع رونالدو كانت الاقصى والاثقل
وقعا على قلوب محبي الاسطوره بعد ما اقصى
المغرب منتخب بلاده البرتغال من البطوله
في مباراه كان فيها على دكه الاحتياط في
الشوط الاول من المباراه
لتعليمات المدرب وعجزه مع رفاقه في اختراق
عرين اسود الاطلس في الشوط الثاني منها
بينما كانت صديقته جورجينا تراقب بدهشه
وتوتر يغادر الملعب بعد الهزيمه الحزينه
وعلق رونالدو على حسابه الرسميه على
الانستغرام كان الفوز بكاس العالم
للبرتغال اكبر حلما في مسيرته واكثرها
طموحا واكمل قائلا للاسف انتهى الحلم امس
اريد فقط ان تعلموا جميعا انه قد قيل
الكثير وكتب الكثير وقد تم التكهن بالكثير
لكن نتانيا للبرتغال لم يتغير للحظه وكنت
دائما مناظلا من اجل هدف الجميع ولندير
ظهري ابدا لزملائي وبلادي وتوجه رولاندو
في ختام تعليقه بالشكر لقطر ووصف كل ما
قيل عن جدليه شركته مع منتخب بلاده في هذه
البطوله لاستنتاجات الخاصه
[موسيقى]
ومن قطر الى السعوديه حيث اختتمت النسخه
الثانيه من مهرجان البحر الاحمر السينمائي
الدولي فعاليتها في جده الاسبوع الماضي
بتكريم الممثل جاكي شان وتتويج الافلام
الفائزه وصناعها بجوائز اليسر في دوره
نجحت مجددا استقطاب النجوم عالميين وتسليط
الدوره على المنجز السينمائي السعودي تحت
شعار السينما كل شيء وفي موسم الرياض
اختتمت عروض المسرحيه المصريه سيده
الجميله من بطوله احمد السقا وريم مصطفى
وممثلين اخرين برؤيه اخراجيه جديده لمصطفى
حسني وذلك بعد الجدل الذي اثارته في مصر
اعاده تقديم المسرحيه الشهيره التي لعب
بطوله نسختها لايقونيه الفنانين الراحلين
فؤاد المهندس وشويكار سنه
1969 وكرم موسم الرياض الاسبوع الماضي
ذكرى موسيقار الاجيال محمد عبد الوهاب في
حفل حضره ابنه انشدت فيه المطربه المصريه
ريهام عبد الحكيم ولوئي مختارات من اعذب
بها الحان الموسيقى الراحل
[موسيقى]
عليه
واخيرا طمانت الفنانه المصريه انغام
محبيها بعد تعرضها لوعكه الصحيه طارئه
مؤخرا اضطرت بعدها لاجراء عمليه جراحيه
كبيره ادت الى مضاعفات تطلبت وقائعها في
المستشفى وعبرت انغام في سلسله تغريدات
على تويتر عن شعورها بالامتنان لكل من
اطمئن عليها ووقف الى جانبها في هذه
المهنه